definitely bring in the pain there
mm-hmm
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Tom Colicchio
he's a James Beard award-winning chef
it's got some Emmys in the trophy case
and can catch him on season 14 of Top
Chef which returns to Bravo on Thursdays
Tom welcome to the show thank you this
is pretty awesome
I feel comforted because I know that you
once saved a party guests life was
choking on chicken right I read a New
York Times article this is this is true
I was standing a hallway notice I turn
turn to my right I saw that it's two
guys patting her on the back and I kind
of walk up behind her and said can you
breathe him she went like this and my
caterer wants us and now enough again
chicken flew out and as it turned out
there was about 50 journalists at the
party and within minutes I got a call
from my wife saying what you do get in
the boats and stuff yeah but it was
pretty crazy but yeah it gives me a
sense of comfort are you ready to start
it gives you a sense a comfort but I'm
going to use a chicken I hope I hope you
can do it
[Music]
I think all heat not our flavor
you know fermentations fine but not not
not a huge fan I want to start by
talking about your near miss but Sex in
the City because from what I understand
you almost had a scene in the pilot but
it had to get scratched due to some
unfortunate circumstances yeah they shot
the pilot at Gramercy Tavern and the day
before combination of a couple things
happen I was playing basketball and
sprained my ankles so bad like I
couldn't stand I have actually bleeding
through my skin it was that bad and I
had the hospital on a walking cast prom
we also had a fire that day and so the
area where they were gonna shoot was in
our sort of wood-burning grill that we
had but we've had a scrap the entire
scene because we couldn't let grill and
I couldn't stand up oh yeah did you feel
at all like you missed an opportunity
like now it's probably easy to look back
and laugh at it but at the time we kind
of like that would've been awesome yeah
at the time who knew was gonna be a hit
which there's a pilot maybe it's more
painful now probably more painful now
yeah but it's it's great show and we
were happy that we could actually help
in the launches I can tell that
Schomberg ER producer creator of hot
ones he really tried with the sauces I
think he was like trying to impress you
like this seems more deliberate and like
the wings are a little warmer tell me
usually get cold wings with hot sauce
don't get we're getting actually hot
wings not sauces ooh got it just for you
Tom these days it seems like the ways in
which a restaurant or a chef can win
it's very varied these days lots of
paths to success and what I want to do
is bounce some scenarios off you it's
just a game of would you rather and you
can tell me what you rather have this or
would you rather have that and then if
you can kind of explain the logic behind
it I'd appreciate it that's how I'm good
sure would you rather get an extra star
from the New York Times or an extra star
from the Michelin Guide when the
Michelin Guide first came to New York
crab got one star and I was interviewed
and someone asked you know what I
thought of the Michelin in New York and
I said I think it's really great this is
the first year if they're here for you
know 10 years 20 years I've embedded
that of a grayble growing up I didn't
dream of Michelin stars I'm an American
chef I dreamed of New York Times stars
and I'll stick to that I still would
rather 1 New York time stone how about 1
five-star yelp reviews are one tweet
from Kanye West saying crafts the
greatest restaurant in the world I'm not
afraid of Yelp but I'll take the Yelp
fails right now yeah yeah I mean kind
Kanye I think he's in the hospital
recovering from you know some brain you
know defect that he has at this point
right yeah we'll take the yo would you
rather win another James Beard Award or
win another Emmy considering that I
still consider myself in the restaurant
business and not in the entertainment
business I'll take I'll take another
beer at work especially since we're
opening a new restaurant and so we'd
probably get nominated for Best new
restaurant and I would take that would
you rather the Obamas come to one of
your restaurants for date night or
Rihanna posted an Instagram with your
signature dish in like a giggling emoji
Obama's in the restaurant no no
competition alright so this one is a
Yucatec Oh chili Abbott is a chili
habanero says habanero yeah that's good
was the show kind of knows the sauce is
kind of doesn't mm-hmm yeah the
distinction of being roasted at a food
policy fundraiser what do you think was
the funniest joke someone got off on you
there was a lot of lighthearted stuff I
think you know Padma got a good put a
couple licks in um I actually roasted
her at the Friars Friars Club roast oh
did she got him back
I had a rebuttal to every single one of
them and I got them all back but it's
you know it's all good fun besides the
heat someone's actually doing a pretty
good job of seasoning these just with
salt so it's pretty good somebody over
there
I could tell that was a child or Eddie
Wong I get this a child I know you
bristle at the thought of chefs being
the new rock stars and in part because
you idolize rock stars are very much a
guitar guy I play a little guitar I
don't say idolizing button I know I have
respect for their craft can I ask you
what would happen if let's say the
hostess at craft what running to the
back of the kitchen and said Eric
Clapton has just taken a seat can you
take me step by step what happens from
there
do you breed him at the table other
dishes that you send out no I don't know
I don't think I've send out you know
I've had over the years plenty of rock
stars come in the restaurant I usually
leave him alone I try to position myself
at the door the other night just to say
goodbye I think that people who come
into the restaurant should give him the
space let the meat let them enjoy
themselves and again I'll I try to just
catch him on the way out
just like the parting gift
immature an addition under cut it with
like a citrus blend no I like the stitch
alright asset you do I think it sounds
yeah this is why it only sriracha it's
just hot there's no sort of background
this doesn't backup flavor have freaking
like it we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that Graham but
you're way too much of an adult for this
segment show but damn you do have great
pictures online we've pulled a couple of
them and we just want the bigger picture
okay you tell me what's going on and
onyx you're beyond what just easy okay
you and Eddie and patton oswalt yeah
the Google Mugen the great Google ooga
in Brooklyn the food festival music
festival and that was the first time I
met Eddie I liked him a lot you know
when I first met him I I know I didn't I
just had to know him and I didn't know
much about his background he told me
that day he said I'm writing book it's
gonna come out I'm gonna have a TV show
and I'm gonna blow wells and I was like
yes sure
okay book TV show a little yeah Tom and
jay-z this is iconic if this isn't
framed in your house then I don't know
that that was at the NBA all-star game
he doesn't event a fundraiser for his
foundation is famous and is wealthy and
successful as the
is he still hasn't gotten too far away
from Queens so Brooklyn ah she's like
this is interesting
oh yeah I was synthesized if I remember
correctly I was in Marge's dream she was
on Top Chef and she was competing and I
said something and then the stove turned
into a car or something and I turned
that actually into my my my Twitter
avatar because you have to if you're
Simpson eyes do you have to yeah at
first it wasn't instead of a picture
being a fish or something I was like no
it's a nice name the game really does
does it's a referential does it ramp up
situation there's a huge debate right
now in the restaurant industry about
whether or not tipping should be
abolished and I know that you've tried
it out and at least one of your
restaurants can you give me an idiot's
guide to why tipping doesn't make any
sense anymore because I think it is hard
for people to wrap their heads around
why should we leave it up to a hundred
to 200 people at night who come into the
restaurant to decide who's how my
employees are going to get paid and how
much they're gonna get paid we want
professionalizing industry we have
professionalized industry and I think
they should get paid like professionals
and they should get paid a wage the
argument is well we're not going to get
a service actually I think the service
will get better why because now if
you're gonna complain you're gonna
complain directly your mate you know if
you complain to a waiter I'm not gonna
find out if you give a waiter bad tip
I'm not gonna find out if you tell me
that someone gives you bad service
number one I'll know number two I'll do
something about it the food's late
that's one of the biggest complaints
food lake or the kitchen that's not the
waiters fault that's the kitchens fault
right now punishing the kitchen right
and so there's a lot of reason why I I
think it's an outdated model but if we
lost it one thing that I would miss out
on are those great stories about
outrageous tips you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah sure you hit the
news you know about Shaq leaving $20,000
behind I love those stories on your
restaurant experience are there any of
those that stand out ah I don't you
again I don't know I don't get involved
in the tips or something got a great tip
it's you know they usually keep Shaq lap
26 behind me no no no yeah no no you're
doing your job you're doing little shake
thing isn't
[Music]
mmm smoked lettuce all your restaurant
craft in Gramercy Tavern they've birthed
some of the most celebrated chefs in
this city for out-of-towners can you
give me some iconic New York dishes that
people would really understand and learn
about New York having tried done
definitely bring in the pain there
mm-hmm
good question I could think of Gotham in
their seafood salad is a real iconic
dishes you know Alfred was the first
chef to start using height on plates and
that seafood tower is just a it's a
classic I would say any raw fish
preparation from Eric repair Le Bernadin
libertà there was one of the first
restaurants to actually bring outside of
Japanese restaurants to bring raw fish
preparations and also under cook you
know lightly cooked fish preparation so
I would say that's a classic um uh God
we think no Coney Island hot dog maybe
huh that's a good yeah
you know I have a bit a little bit of a
sinus issue and this time we're cleaning
it up it's clearing it up yeah well
you're welcome Tom yes good what's next
so this one is de bomb beyond insanity
glasses are on what makes this beyond
sanity about to run out
mm I know you're very involved in food
policy and you really put your money
where your mouth is you go to Capitol
Hill you confront Congress face to face
but it does open yourself up to a
certain type of Internet role a certain
type of criticism that even when you're
championing something the very common
sense like child hunger people will
still go after you when people say Tom
go back to the kitchen make food stop
thinking about hunger you get kind of a
kick out of that or does it bother you
no it neither because I think that it's
so it should be right in this country to
feel committed to have food also to have
nutritious food not not just garbage if
someone has a problem with my politics
and think I should stay in the kitchen
let's look at food through different
lens because I think if you look at some
of the topics of the day that people
really care about whether it's the
economy whether it's health care whether
it's from whoo that was hot
health care national security and the
environment food actually could fix all
that my guess is there are certain
things that you think you know what when
it starts to bring your ears is that a
problem no that means that means that
means the shows going just according to
plan there's probably some issues where
you like well that's a pretty
complicated solve and then maybe there
are other issues where you're just like
this seems so easy to me why can't we do
it is there one issue that stands out to
you as being like the most frustrating
thing hunger is easy sometimes not
poverty's harder well sometime you know
because the two if they don't have it
they don't actually absolutely go hand
in hand
when I say hunger is easier because we
produce enough food in this country to
feed everyone so if you look at
countries where people are literally
starving
it's usually because of famine because
of war because of drought because we're
actually producing enough calories for
for their citizens we do here we produce
more than enough food so really people
are hungry not because we don't have
enough food they're hungry because we
don't have the political will to make
sure everyone's fed that's what's
frustrating are you ready to move on
it's it's hahaha maybe you know I my
mouth is fine lips are on fire
mm-hmm I start getting hurt tomorrow yep
we don't make you do any of this time I
know at this point I can't stop right
I'm the last doing the way do you really
[ __ ] out one more wing well you know
what you know for [ __ ] life you can't
have that on the internet forever but I
want to do this little Top Chef
rapid-fire to you drawing on all those
seasons that you have it's not gonna be
easy to think this through the mad dog
357 but we're gonna do it Tom no 57
touch my bed tom is a gee look at Tom
favorite guest judge um favorite guest
judge Oh God
I mean the obvious one whatever you want
to hear me say ethnic Bourdain oh man he
was always great to have around Charlize
Theron cuz at one point she just turn
around said does anybody this remember
an Oscar no then shut up the past winner
that you've been most proud of um you
know proud of Mo I think think going
back to number one I think Harold
because I think represented France so
well I'm representing go out there and
go on the on the chef's tour and the
whole bit he actually opened up a few
restaurants and did really well for a
while and I think you know he was the
first one and I think he really set the
standard for everything that came into
it you ever get into it with producers
always wonder this behind-the-scenes
because there are probably people that
like you know they're a fan favorite
they're an instigator or whatever maybe
you get a couple weeks past your
expiration date so from day one which I
think been great about the show is that
the producers and I say this with with
I'm a producer so I I do have a sign it
but the producers don't have that get
involved at all in who stays and who
goes
we really don't get occasionally if
we're trying to make a tough decision
you know we may hear one from the
background saying well you know this
one's a better character and we're like
it doesn't matter right they don't taste
the food they have absolutely no no say
at all and who they
who goes so it's last one is bears
Megadeth sauce with liquid rage it's
tradition around here to put a little
dab on the last wing okay Tom you don't
have to if you don't want to them I
guess to do it that's right nothing
that's in a way that's where I thought
this was going on this is all fine
little battle do you yeah there we go I
like I like as it has technique I like
mine we have chefs well you know you
want to move that no hey you might pay
for that and probably next couple days
yeah I'm going to let me preface this
question before we take a bite okay okay
I'm always curious about your thought
process when you're judging a dish so
I'd like to sort of present this last
wing to you as if it were a dish on Top
Chef and if you can just speak your
thought process out and as much detail
as possible if you were to judge this
dish and I'd like to present it to you
sort of like um Top Chef style just goes
like this is what I would say um I
present a carry-out wing from b-dubs
it's been tossed and blares Megadeth
sauce with a liquid rage to get full
coverage we serve it room temperature on
wood with a milk chaser enjoy Cheers um
boom first is it cooked properly
was it overcooked is it undercooked is
it seared properly if it's a wing it
should be little crunchy right so is it
crunchy then it's a seasoned properly
which is really thought this is just
seasoned right now you tell me it has
Megadeth sauce on it so I expect it to
be hot so the question is is it hot [ __ ]
yeah it's hot um sometimes I'll ask you
chef if they overcook something was your
intention would your intention how did
you want to serve this if they say
medium-rare now it's not meeting America
you screwed up
they say medium but why would you serve
a medium is that the best way to serve
it and let them hang that's how slow
yeah alright and then you're looking at
everything else around the dish so in
this case it would be the wood board in
there yeah
the hot sauce but it doesn't all make
sense as you know as you eat it - all
those bytes make sense can you get a
different bite or do they all work
together did that bite make sense this
bike makes sense yeah we got a weave to
finish this way no yeah I got a whip
finish okay does this make sense
mm-hmm absolutely not but it was a lot
of fun but I made it through you cleared
the board this camera that camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life my wife and I along with
food policy action and it placed the
table campaign we're actually launching
an anti hunger campaign the first lady
will will be in our first PSA and we're
launching sometime in December who's
hungry in this country why they're
hungry what we can do about it and the
fact that we can actually take care of
hunger in our lifetime in this country
so that our children our children's
children don't have to not only not too
hungry themselves but don't have to
witness people in this country without
food so that's that's the next thing on
our agenda
[Music]
you